[Musik]
ich habe eine wassermelone getragen
herrscht ein witz verstanden
dirty dancing kenne ich nicht will ich
auch gar nicht kennt ist es um das
pervers mit tieren und dann möchte ich
sagen das ist ein schöner film
wir haben leider erst später entdeckt
haben herzlich willkommen zur tennis
welt heute haben wir uns gedacht machen
wir einen wasserwellen contest oder
wassermelone chapman versys maschine
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum habe ich eigentlich die
wassermelone und so die schlanke weil
immer günstiger weil die günstigen okay
also spielregeln murat ich weiß heute
schon mal du hast schon recherchiert
ich wollte nämlich eigentlich dass wir
jetzt einfach zwei minuten lang
recherchieren so of interest google
youtube irgendwo und wassermelonen
vorlagen uns anschauen und dann sahen
wir uns derzeit festmachen wie lange wir
schon mal geschockt wie schnitzen der
wassermelone ok und dürfen einander
nicht zugucken ok und dann am ende
entscheiden die zuschauer was am
schlimmsten ist also das ist wir haben
das ding ist sofort wie damals in der
schule nicht abgucken
ja richtig ich hatte immer die leute die
gesagt haben für murat schaut ab und dem
ok das heißt ich hab was vor du hast es
vor und wir machen was für eine coole
gartenparty ja ist eine inspiration sein
für eine coole gartenparty etwas selber
machen die idee ich habe eine idee und
ihr entscheiden nachher oder was man
ledig und nicht fertig hast du schon
fertig hatte recherchiert meisterschaft
zu machen
ich gucke jetzt mal was ist da gibt ich
gucke jetzt mehr und zwar die coolsten
ideen holt euch wirklich bike interest
oder müssen nur eingeben wassermelonen
gartenparty zum beispiel ich habe eine
idee weil ich habe das schon mal gemacht
das weißt du nicht mehr aber ich hab das
schon mal gemacht und zwar werde ich
machen
hast du was und zwar mache ich das hier
seht ihr das
nikolaus oder das hätte ich auch gern
gemacht aber da ich muslim bin geht es
gar nicht wenn es bestimmt gerade
schwein gesehen ja das wäre herr am main
ich mache das hier ist dass frank maries
sie das okay ich mache das hier und zwar
folgendes bei jenas hier
ich brauche noch hin werden aber ich
brauche noch ein controller für schweine
ich brauche vier kfz von dem plan
ja habe ich und dann hätte ich noch gern
von playmobil findest zwei piraten ich
hätte gerne anpackt und prinzessin oder
noch mit dem nektar oder in panik gerät
und denkst und kirchenordnung mit
kirschen mit du denkst zwar du weißt was
ich mache habe ich recht einigen bringst
du nur noch ein halbes hähnchen mit
jetzt mit becker bringst du noch ein
halbes hähnchen mit knusprig mit kräuter
marinade herrscht hunger nein
ein brötchen dazu noch gehört jetzt weiß
ich nicht mehr erwartet nicht mal ein
elite doch nicht so werde ich wohl
machen vielleicht mache ich doch nicht
das vielleicht 40 erfolg aber ich weiß
nicht ob ich das hinkriege
da war er war oder ich es ist zeit noch
meine stärken braucht man die
wassermelone
[Musik]
aber darf ich vielleicht meine
wassermelone noch kurz tauschen also
dass ich finde man macht wissen was man
hat aber ich hätte gerne rundere wasser
mit oder darf ich zu tauschen
ja mein team sagt ja du kannst auch du
nehmen wenn du wiedersehen zwischen
nicht die zweite waren eigentlich werfen
besser verrückt als werkzeug habe ich
hier ein saldo co2 tomatenmesser und
dann wieder agieren
ich habe messer unseren okay ich fange
jetzt einfach anders
es muss fair sein alle hast du hier für
werkzeuge dass du kannst dich hier dran
auch bei ihnen das ist natürlich jetzt
sehen was ich mache was ist das jetzt
hast du gesehen was ich wieder ich wehre
mich gesehen aber mich kriegt wohl auch
dass ich freue mich schon wird das ist
ein apfel entkernt
ja darf zu nehmen das ist eine paprika
haut entfernen oder ein stück in die
kerne auslösen
wir sind solche sachen gibt das ist eine
dünnere haut ohne okay bei deinen füßen
und dann hab ich immer so kugel
ausstechen
ok kannst du auch nimmt und das hier ist
eine orangenscheibe ich muss das jetzt
gar nicht dass das duo so will ich habe
hier mein land ist ein ich weiß gar
nicht wann ich will es gar nicht
ich versuche ja auch an wie ich könnte
auch mit steinschleudern löwen erleben
wir kein problem ich bin man ok auf los
geht's los ich würde sagen gestoppten
auch die zeit stelle denn kaymer auf 30
minuten kaymer wird eingestellt und los
so etwas zu erklären was ich zu machen
also folgendes ich werde hier einen
präzisen chirurgische schnitte durch die
mit ihm machen nicht das schon nämlich
das messer wohl angst dass ich mir
vielleicht weil ich weiß dass das
problem auch ist dass die wassermelone
nicht aufreißt weil dies auch spannung
wenn das hier schneidet reißt so oft das
ist jetzt eher wann ist ein problem ich
gemacht schon manche sagen zu viele
gedanken und deswegen funktioniert dann
nicht mache es jetzt gerade gesagt das
funktioniert bei mir nicht
wie gesagt das was ich das jetzt nicht
mehr nötig ist ich glaube sowie brauchen
auch keines reicht vollkommen
das tue ich jetzt einfach auskratzen und
wohl um eine schüssel und der rest
natürlich hier rein und tut es nachher
im mixer zu manchen und machen
wassermelonen eis aus also wie gesagt
mit dem nichts wegschmeißen müsst ihr
wirklich nicht so können wir nicht alles
verwenden
[Musik]
ich habe ja auch falsches stück gegessen
so jetzt das wasser ein prequel das
reicht es auch vollkommen jetzt hier
nicht zu viel wegnehmen weil ich brauche
hier noch ein bisschen futter um was
rein zu machen
ok jetzt noch ein bisschen schön dass
auch noch schön aussieht guck mal ich
jetzt einfach aber dass ihr unternehmen
mit dem rest rückt für ein gerät auch
mit den handschuhen arbeiten ich habe
meine hände gewaschen ja wo hat meisten
unfälle passieren im haushalt weiß das
weil es keine schublade offen stellen ja
jetzt mache ich hier auch einfach mitte
mit dem mit dem ding hier rein drücken
wenn wir das nicht hat wenn wir das
nicht hat dann kann man es auch anders
machen kann nicht kurz denn locker haben
bitte bei den abbitte ich habe ihn nie
aufgegeben nur kurz ich brauche nur zwei
löcher nur zwei oder drei löcher jetzt
habe ich es so weit fertig und jetzt
wird es noch die seite bis die ihn mit
dem mit den restlichen zutaten kommt und
jetzt muss ich das auch aushöhlt akku
welcher in 30 sekunden akku leer
auf jeweils so muss es aussieht und ich
mache jetzt mal ein fotografisches
gedächtnis
ok
[Musik]
ich habe mein bestes stück da das ding
vergessen das was meint ihr ausmacht was
den tieren jetzt weiß ich was du machst
kohl gab es jetzt klappt dann zum ewigen
angezeichnet und wenn das mal entlang
steigen ist was für dich was will ich so
jetzt muss ich anfangen erst mal bis zu
machen
ich kann es auch nicht arbeiten das wäre
schön sauber gemacht
und wie gesagt ich sage es nochmal zum
dritten mal bitten nichts wegschmeißen
damit kann nachher richtig cooles wasser
mir nun sorgen
so jetzt fällt ist die wichtigen
bisschen reduzieren das heißt so viel
fleisch wie möglich bequem
wir haben auch fünf minuten 34
das geht gar nicht das ist unmöglich
doch wir haben das waren die spielregeln
wie das waren die spielregeln den
zölibat sei es auch wichtig geht ja
alles ohne hammer
das wäre noch dass ein bisschen im rat
macht mich fertig der macht bis zu
nervös geht es von vorne ja nicht
komplett gerade jetzt kommen die
praktisch so irgendwie dran also muss
ich unten gerade also und das komisch
weil es jetzt kugel drin sie kann man
die kugel raus nach nachher aber
natürlich im kühlschrank lagern etwa
kühl werden lassen da mache ich jetzt
noch pakula stücke ein paar beeren mache
ich rein dann willst du ein richtig
cooler fruchtsalat also okay dann
stoppen wir an der stelle
ich gucke da es nicht amtlich doch mal
kurz die zeit wenn es noch zwei minuten
10 okay also 21 10
wir stoppen weil wir jetzt auf zutaten
warten warten und kannst das gebäude
gleich schnell waren ja in der
zwischenzeit zimmer aufräumen zum
aufräumen
ich stopfe kurzer zeit händler und da
geht es gleich weiter wie es euch gesagt
haben wir machen wir wollen jetzt auch
in der zwischenzeit oder zwischenzeit
wirklich nichts wegschmeißen müssen wir
wirklich absolut nicht jetzt nehme ich
einfach ich nehme handschuh dazu ok
zeige ich euch kurz
ich habe keine an schulen doch ich hab
schon hier will ich will ich es wenn ich
nachher möchten ihnen die sich essen da
drin - essen ja ich habe es echt
gewaschen ich habe mich auch ich habe
auch nicht die jogi löw gemacht
so jetzt nehmen wir das einfach und thun
lässt herein was wir auch machen können
ich habe vorher noch dass das wasser
noch abgeschöpft und das könnt ihr auch
mit reimann das sind zwar gerne drin
aber normalerweise müsste ist er mixa
schaffen
die komplett zu sagen siehst du nachher
gar nicht dessen zusätzliche
ballaststoffe habe ich recht
[Musik]
so ich hab noch ein bisschen abgeschöpft
ist war es zuviel jetzt nur noch ein
bisschen in coolen geschmack noch
zusätzlich zu dem rhein
und zwar habe ich hier noch bananen
rhein zwar genau hier aber noch zitrone
und die trübe ich jetzt einfach rein
eine zitrone noch übrig habt so habe ich
jetzt gerade dann einfach in die
spülmaschine rhein ist ein cooles theo
und ein cooler schmutz löse zusätzlich
[Musik]
hettich und wisse was es ganz coole ist
für leute die diese diese firma kerner
kern johannes b kerner also jeder der
diese kerne nicht toll findet werde
diese kern nicht nie werden komplett
zerstört die spürst doch gar nicht an
die jungs raus energie und alex
[Musik]
ich habe erfrischung für euch recht
banal juni wollt net fahrscheine auch an
die anderen ja warum
der ist kemper name sagen doch weil die
märkte sich das paar nahm ich sage immer
wieder zusammen ich habe seinen seinen
pass war keine banane trainer war echt
ja ich habe jetzt eine banane
da muss ich dann immer geben also jungs
hier bei frisch und für euch
[Musik]
oben also gefühlt haben wir unsere
wassermelone jetzt schon jetzt werden
sie fertigt operiert ich starte jetzt
wieder die zeit okay wenn es alle
zutaten her gerechnet warte und los zwei
minuten 10 kann jetzt meine augen machen
so nachdem er die abwehrreihe gemacht
hat dann schön hinten das hühnchen
platzieren kann ja damit es richtig toll
wird dieses was macht fahrzeug was
machst du morath und zwar nehme ich hier
noch einen halben für sich diesen halben
für sich und schneide ich jetzt 40 und
halbieren meine ich jetzt
jetzt denkt ihr bestimmt alle was macht
der junge mann vom coolen tricks drauf
und zwar so
man muss einfach wissen es sind
gleichwertig und dann folgendes jetzt
hab ich was ganz ganz tolles und zwar
habe ich hier ein bauer von playmobil
oder playmobil gab es ganz vergessen es
war
der bauer hat die zeit ist vorbei heute
kümmern weiter machen ja noch zwei
wieder okay jeder darf noch kurz
bäckerin ja
ja hat es so als kleines geld immobilien
ein jahr zuvor
ich hatte nie playmobil was ist das eine
kette playmobil ist nein was für reiche
kids gewesen
das hat mir nicht ein einhorn die fliegt
und reiter sieht man die überhaupt von
vorne musste weiter nach rechts braucht
die kinder versorgen brett zum
draufstellen ja ein podest
das ist wohl noch ein paar blaubeeren
weit bist du denn eigentlich so gut wie
fertig ich mache so bisher noch so
mädchen.de kohkamp ich das wirklich
kraftvoll einmal die glasmacher weiß ich
war immer ausgemalt ohne wc und die
mädels waren immer zuerst fertig das ist
la peau die jungs noch schreiben und die
mädchen die geschichte ausmalen
die regenbogen passt auch gut in diesem
sommer wenn mädchen einkaufen gehen
[Applaus]
ich bin fertig ich bin fertig ich auch
weniger uns entscheiden lassen was auch
jemanden der storch gesehen hat weil ich
mir fragen die ok aber ich habe das die
zuschauer
okay wir machen hier eine abstimmung und
die zuschauer dürfen auch abstellen nach
unten was wir sagen aber nicht mehr wo
gearbeitet hat ohne könig soll
entscheiden was wirklich okay aber dann
macht er auch seinen arbeitsplatz niveau
gearbeitet also noch gesehen arbeiten
als sauber und danach das main gar nicht
gesehen und ich dazu nicht kommt
manchmal die wand weg
[Musik]
hast du ehrlich ein schwein gemacht nein
ein schwein kuh einhorn das ist aber das
ist ein schwein kreiner und guckt das
ist eine schöne chance das sieht doch
aus wie der kuh schnauze und deko okay
es ist das bei der co die haben wir die
hörner und nein horn und die prinzessin
tv und regenbogen ja ich hab gedacht nur
natürliche sachen die sonst so
gummibären zeug drin ist eine playmobil
figur drauf und das eisenstäbe drauf
ok und was macht das weiß ich jetzt dass
ich jetzt gleich und ich bin ich so
entscheiden was schöner etwas schönes
region hat okay okay aber ich bin echt
also ich muss echt sagen hast echt gut
gemacht
stets hat er uns wissen der nektarine
was man nicht aber die chance haben soll
eine schatztruhe habe ich auch ja ach
kammern oder und jetzt mal jetzt
ungelogen ich meine wir müssen beim
training immer länger drehen also wir
haben eine stunde gedreht
aber wenn jetzt nicht drehen würden aber
wir haben 30 minuten genau ich würde
sagen jetzt zwischen schwierig werden es
braucht um nicht länger als 30 minuten
um zwei so coole sachen zu machen und
zwei kommen und cocktails der einkauf
hat uns dann aufgehalten werden 30
minuten gedreht also noch zwei halb drei
und dann noch mal die zwei minuten und
dann nochmal monats fünf minuten
unterging fragen wir was am besten also
ich muss echt sagen ich könnte mich
nicht entscheiden denn ich finde beide
das ist ziemlich cool schalten tier und
das schalten chef also ich finde man am
besten muss ehrlich sein als hier auf
jeden fall bin ich richtig in der jury
sitzen würde würde ich mir jetzt die
volle punktzahl geben seht ihr das nicht
sagen wir jetzt mit murat macht keiner
gemacht was ich mich da hier liegen
kommen holt ein frei master hier einfach
ich bei ihr wirken
berlins tagen war bemüht
oder hat sich war bemüht ich war kreativ
ja kreativ aber das ziel verfehlt
rollators gewonnen
ich will auch dass wohl einfach gemacht
da sieht er ja okay ist sehen an dem
einhorn mann gefallen und ich mache das
hier niemand arbeitsplatz mir egal ich
weiß der kunde hat immer was gegen mich
deswegen ist er bestimmt 100 prozent
juni an leider schon feierabend wenn es
schon 14 uhr und da er sich sein da es
seit zehn jahren in altersteilzeit
befindet sind zwischen märkte blieben
höchste alex star alex jetzt alles ich
bin jetzt einfach ganz fair zu sein
wenn du jetzt wenn du das jetzt sehen
würde und welches kindergeburtstag und
kinder und die kinder würden das
anschauen und aber was will der party
was wird schon richtig cool finden dann
ist der widerstandskampf ok ich hab' ich
weiß ich habe mir jetzt nicht so viel
ich hab' ich hab's halt einfach gemacht
ich wollte halt weil ich so nicht sagen
wer was gemacht hat ja ich wollte dann
einfach nur ein bisschen
mir war auch langweilig wird besorgt
auf jeden fall ok also jetzt alles was
wird nicht mehr ansprechend sei ganz
ganz ehrlich jetzt schon von vorne und
von überall gesehen
guck mal hier die habe ich dann ganz
einfach hin gemacht die füße ich habe
das einfach das haben wir doch auf der
insel manipulieren dass sie einen 314
seiner crew ein schwein und dann ein
heim für eine verkappte würde ich auf
jeden fall
herrliches nach gott
[Musik]
schade alexa leider muss ich sagen dass
ich das gemacht habe
so leben habe ich gewonnen und
manipuliert kümmern foto von uns zwei
machen
also ich hab es den contest gewonnen
alex hat entschieden
ich persönlich hätte mir auch wird
schickele hängt ja alles was hatte ich
noch dazu bewegt jetzt klar segler aber
die auch die details ja dass er an tor
gleich wo ich für igel und das schwein
co einmal es ist hart natürlich dafür ja
wie gesagt wir lassen ihn glaube ich die
zuschauer entscheiden also er dafür
jetzt auch noch mal abstimmen
seit er timo rath oder themen sally
schreibt in die kommentare
es geht aber hier nicht dabei darum
partei zu ergreifen sondern welches
geschnitzte welt geht eine junge frau
will 80 prozent von cs zuschauer
zwischen 1854 uns in waiblingen und sind
weiblich sind sowieso alles biete ich
sage ganz ganz ehrlich und was ist auch
regionaler genau und denk dir noch daran
dass ich eine schwere kindheit hatte ja
denken solche dinge auch noch mit und
falls ihr wollt dass wir öfter solche
contest zu machen und wenn die ideen
habt schreibt sie gerne in die
kommentare
schiedsrichter leider ausgeschieden aber
dann geschah also dann werden jetzt im
team natürlich ist ja alles essen wir
werden wie immer mit kühlen es erstmal
und die sind alle voll von dem
wassermelonen / ich dachte bedanke mich
noch mal schon mal für den sieg auch für
euren sympathien mir gegenüber arbeiten
bin echt stolz auf dich
was verdient geholt das sagt
[Musik]